I want to talk about this uh this other
story we gotta we're gonna get serious
here we got this from timcast.com
Twitter suspends account that simply
provided gilaine Maxwell trial updates
the account Maxwell trial tracker had
only been active for two weeks but had
over 525 000 followers the big Tech
Giant claimed the court updates violated
their policy against platform
manipulation and spam the owner of the
account the free press report run on
their subject page that all other
accounts they have made in the past were
also suspended my understanding here is
that they were doing a bunch of tracking
of a bunch of different issues
politically and Twitter nuked the
account took them all down now a lot of
people are saying this is Twitter trying
to make sure people can't figure out
what's going on with the Maxwell trial
but some people have also said the trial
is basically a cover-up anyway well how
many witnesses they call only a handful
nothing like no major players and
they're already winding it down is that
what's going on essentially pretty much
yeah I mean prince Andrew should have
been there uh Trump should have been
there Bill Clinton should have been
there they should have been testifying
what they saw what was going on they
should have been held under Earth and
again to me this is a larger cover-up
operation from the beginning and and I
think the media coverage reflects on it
because we found out you know little
tidbits there about how many times
Jeffrey Epstein visited the Bill Clinton
white house uh we found out other people
who flew on the Lolita Express we found
out a lot of the really illicit uh
things that happened on that airplane
that we can't even mention on this
broadcast so so there's little tidbits
of information that we got but the main
way people were finding out that
information was through this Twitter
account that has amassed close to a half
a million users who were following it
who are paying close attention to it and
were doing the job that the corporate
media should have been doing I'm going
to ask a question I know the answer to
but I'm going to play dumb anyway who
was who's the prosecutor on this
uh the lead prosecutor prosecutor is a
rookie prosecutor the prosecuting team
also has James comey's daughter the
person who accidentally deleted the
Jeffrey Epstein footage when he was in
the jail originally from his originally
alleged first suicide attempt so she's a
part of the problem this is such a
Brazen and open operation do you think
that they just decided to be like hey
you know what we're just gonna do this
we know everybody's going to criticize
us for doing this but it's better than
what would happen if we didn't let me
let me know what you guys watching think
right now
I think everyone's going to say yes but
like did they take down this Twitter
account because it was providing
information on the Maxwell trial was
this a deliberate attempt to stop the
information from getting out well this
was one of the few ways that the
information was getting out it was
getting out there to a lot of people so
just on that basic Merit there is reason
to believe that and a lot of people are
asking why did this happen give us a
reasonable excuse tell us what generic
vague made up traitor rule that they
violated right and Twitter hasn't been
that responsive Twitter hasn't come
forward with any evidence with any
explanation here that I've seen that
justifies this larger takedown of
something that is of such public
interest right with that kind of scale
they should give in they should give a
public declaration as to why they did it
is there not uh a Intrepid up and coming
local journalist wherever this trial is
being held who's sitting in there live
tweeting everything and trying to get
live tweets fine fine fine fine walking
out into the hallway and then tweeting
you're gonna leave the building yeah
gosh you guys killing me is there not
somebody like that some like 23 year old
and reporters who's got like 3 000
followers technically there isn't
because when you go into these buildings
in in in in in the federal courts they
take your phone from you you then have
to go to the courtroom and sit down then
you have to leave check check your tag
and get your phone back and go outside
tweet then walk back hand the phone back
in and you're missing parts of the trial
sure so there are people I think daily
wires got somebody who's been giving
some insights but it's very difficult
the best thing people can do is sit
there with a notebook taking notes if
they even allow that to be completely
honest and then leave and then start
tweeting one by one what's going on but
that's at the end of the day so this
account that's giving as much detail as
possible probably because a bunch of
other people look if you've got 10
people and they're coming on different
periods and and tweeting things you've
got one centralized account that's
sharing this information making it easy
for people to digest Twitter nukes that
account and now who do we follow you
might follow one guy who's covering it
but it's only giving you one 10 to the
information
so to me this it's just it's just
sometimes it's too obvious and I'm sick
and tired because you'll hear this in
the media they'll say oh they're
conspiracy theorists for thinking that
oh okay the one major main like the
major account consolidating all this
information gets suspended for spam and
manipulation
no I'm sorry I don't buy them show us
evidence we need proof this is in the
invested public interest the demand to
know they accuse Veritas of this didn't
they they claim that James O'Keefe was
was like using like manipulating
accounts and having a Bots or something
yeah or running multiple accounts and I
think that's why James sued he's like
I've never run multiple accounts what
are you talking about that's what they
took him down for it's a trick it's what
they did I think they did the same thing
with Miley Annapolis now I don't know
how much I trust Milo when he says he
didn't do this but Twitter was like you
know running multiple accounts or
something I believe that's what happened
I could be wrong and then I'm like you
got to prove that you can I've looked
into this you can run multiple accounts
you can't run multiple accounts for the
sake of avoiding a ban is what is what
the rule is last time last I looked into
it but I'm just sort of appalled at like
this idea that the regime basically I
think I saw cernovich talking about this
that the regime is basically deciding to
take a credibility hit instead of
letting
the facts come out like yeah it's clear
that we're covering things up haha we're
definitely covering things up our
corruption the extent to which we're
willing to go to hide the stuff is an
acceptable thing to expose whereas not
the content is acceptable to expose this
kind of makes me feel optimistic
I mean these These are desperate acts by
desperate people what they did to
Veritas with the FBI raids against James
has that has that not been remedied in
some way somewhat um they just won a
special master I think it's called at
the FBI who's going to oversee the
documents They seized or like an extra
third party is going to do that or
something so that's a victory for
Veritas but the fact that they raid
Veritas I think the courts ruled they
can't relay certain documents saying the
privacy of you know Ashley Biden or
whatever
desperation they're scared taking down
this account is overt I think it's I
think it's reasonable for us to assume
that the trends that are in place are
going to worsen and not improve so the
corruption that's on display the chaos
that's out there the disorder that's
coming the the Brazen uh Brazen cop
chapter uh Brazen uh you know just cover
up and and illegitimacy of all this is
is only going to get worse can you even
consider one alternative universe or
some Factor at all that would that would
like act as a damper on these these
Trends worsening so we should we should
expect to see more of this in these
death rattles and I think the story that
we're going to get to a little bit later
is is part is part of all this I would
say that's more uh about about the the
axios poll than about oh yeah definitely
we'll jump to that but I would say that
they're definitely more Brazen than
desperate I mean for over 30 years they
were able to run an international child
extortion trafficking operation with the
help and assistance for from almost
everyone in law enforcement and politics
and big Tech in the corporate media all
playing along all hanging out uh
McCain's wife even said we all knew he
what he was doing but we just couldn't
do anything because he was connected who
is he connected to to of course the
intelligence agencies and one of the
last tweets that this Twitter account
that was taken down was them tweeting
about the FBI information that was
seized the hard drives the CDs and they
talked about how a lot of the evidence
was correspondent with FBI tags that
looked like they were previously on them
before they were even you know tagged
and categorized by the FBI so again the
FBI was involved here the intelligence
agencies were involved here for over 30
plus years doing unspeakable things
horrible things for children knowingly
for political power for extortion four
whatever was going on here because we
still only know very little about
exactly what was happening here but the
little we know is absolutely sickening
it's terrified to make everyone feel
absolutely horrid about government did
you see the story about the CIA analysts
yeah of course that doesn't surprise me
looking at uh um disgusting or no no
trying to solicit we'll keep it family
friendly a child and they were like yeah
but if we prosecute this guy State
Secrets could get out so you know how
often has that been going on it's really
funny because it's like
how right is Alex Jones because I'm
telling you at this point when he's
talking about interdimensional beings
and like human cow hybrids and cell
towers I'm starting to get scared I'm
like this thing's true this thing I
think Joe was saying he's like pull that
Meme up and it's like he's right about
this this and now we're like human chimp
hybrids and he's like I don't know I'm
just saying right it's like a list you
are here right yeah that that that's
where I'm kind of like you know what I'm
ready to believe like we've seen all of
these things that everyone said was was
crazy conspiracy nonsense about elitist
government-affiliated you know
um abusers and now it's like more and
more information is coming up on top of
the CIA thing is what Luke was just
mentioning that it appears the FBI had
this evidence and had tagged it before
and did nothing yep for how long was it
20 years well the whole operation went
on for at least 30 years from what we
know because there was there was victims
coming to the FBI in 1996. 1996 the FBI
sat down interviewed and investigated
allegedly Epstein there was a lot of
victims coming forward there's a lot of
police officers that tried to do
something they were stopped State
prosecutors were stopped politicians
were stopped judges were stopped and
they were told you can't touch this guy
but if you do we're going to give him
special treatment and I think if we
really understood the horrors that the
government is capable of we can't even
fathom what they are capable of because
what little we know is still we can't
mention it we can't talk about it here
on the show we should be able to we can
well family friendly of course there's
no one telling us we can't talk about
exactly what Epstein did other than we
don't want to scare your children and
freak people out so let's just say
atrocities against minors and children
that were tax funded with your money
world leaders involved Bill Clinton Bill
Gates even Donald Trump flying on these
planes when did Clinton get involved
well Clinton was involved with Epstein
as as far as the early 90s so you see in
the White House logs even Jeffrey
Epstein being an official guest inside
of The White House so did they know each
other beforehand some people are saying
most likely yes a lot of people are also
saying that he knew Donald Trump and
Bill Gates a lot longer than previously
known and again a lot of the secrets
went away with him from his alleged
suicide which one of the prosecutors in
the Glenn Maxwell case just magically
deleted and got rid of the footage yeah
the footage and you know is that that's
like a widely accepted fact yes she
released the press release explaining
why footage mysteriously was disappeared
and no longer existed of the first
suicide that was her they just don't
care they just don't care no no they
just don't care what people think right
it's just an open it's an open operation
I disagree I think they're freaking out
I think this is sheer haddock no no no
hear what you're just saying but they
just don't care about like these acts
that they're taking to cover up these
things that they're panicking like keep
their head down I hear you're saying but
I I think they do care I think they're
just sweating bullets going what do we
do and they're like we have to keep
walking delete the footage and it's like
oh my gosh people are gonna know we did
it it's like we have no choice man yeah
no that's probably no one do it that's
exactly and they have they're shaking
man and they have thousands of photos
thousands of videos we're not talking
about just a few politicians the
politicians we mentioned here thousands
of pieces of evidence that is in their
hands that has extreme political power
because they could come to whatever
politician whatever celebrity whatever
corporate media representative whatever
big Tech uh personality whatever guy
that worked at Microsoft they could come
to him and be like hey look at look at
these nice photos and videos we have
here we need you to promote fake meat we
need you to release GMO mosquitoes we
need you to release contraception that's
going to be controlled by us they could
do that metaphorically speaking
hypothetically
I want to talk about what's going on
with these documents and the evidence
they've had they've been sitting on and
I I and I want to say this I I've seen
the memes on the Trump forums where they
say I don't care who's implicated
I want the evidence out and I've seen
the same thing from people on the left
they're everyone in the populist kind of
you know regular working-class American
types are basically saying release all
the evidence we want it how do we get a
major Grassroots movement between left
and right to be like hey everybody we're
going to stop arguing with each other
just for one minute because we know they
have evidence on Epstein in these Global
Elites and what they were doing and we
all want to know who it is but that
Trove has so much power to the FBI the
FBI is becoming more political by the
day even through their founding with J
Edgar Hoover they were exploiting
Secrets spying on individuals and using
that for political power so for them to
have this weapon this power I do not see
them giving that up I see them holding
it indefinitely for themselves because
it works too much in their favor and it
works in too much of what they always
it's it's their routine business it's
what they always did so I there should
be a bipartisan push I I'm all for it uh
I don't know how we do this but I think
starting the conversation is very
important why AI hasn't Maxwell come out
and just thrown everyone under the bus
there's a lot of things happening behind
the scenes that we do not know there
could be some promises there could be
some deals being like look you know
we'll we'll give you like a 10 10 year
prison sentence but you'll do five and
you'll just come out of it she could
have threatened them by doing that and
then they could have doubled down on her
she's also being tortured allegedly
according to her defense in the very
corrupt prison system that she's in
she's in one of the worst prison systems
that exists in all of the United States
places where the toilets are literally
overflowing with crap I don't buy it I I
I I I I do listening at the listening
for the listening similar from similar
stories coming out of that specific jail
that jail is absolutely corrupted and
it's known for abusing prisoners I don't
believe anything pertaining to any of
this stuff all right I I would be more
inclined to believe that she's sitting
in an underground luxury bunker and
they're like we're so sorry about this
Miss Maxwell don't worry once is all
over we'll let everyone think you're in
prison and you'll be on a private island
minding your own business I agree that's
also a possibility here that's also one
of the things with how Brazen they are
with how crazy they are that they could
probably pull this off as well to make
this a part of their cover-up operation
I think both are possible but we need
more evidence we need more transparency
we need more oversight and we need this
huge Injustice that happened to
thousands of children to be rectified
and it's not we need that evidence we
need that extortion power taken away
from the state immediately let's uh
let's let's do this we have the story
from CNN Democrats officially have a
retirement problem so there's a lot of
people saying that there's going to be a
red wave because of the uh because
historically there should be just you
know because we got a democrat in the
presidential office so people are going
to vote Republican how about this
becomes one of the most important issues
for every constituent in the country or
at the very least those that are
watching tell your friends I'll tell you
this come Christmas time when you're
having those political arguments here's
what you should do you should be like
you know you've got and you got that
annoying Aunt you know Sally or whatever
and she's like young Joe Biden blah blah
blah and just go you know what you know
what I might disagree with you on that
but you think Epstein was bad right how
about we demand of all politicians
this is the issue because can that can
that unite us perhaps right Democrats
are bailing out crazy right you would
think you would think that would unite
us but then well actually that one
teacher who came out with the minor
attracted persons thing didn't she have
to quit right wasn't there like a
professor who came out like made some
presentations so so there's not like so
this was a question I'm sorry we can get
back to what you just said but this was
something I want to think about earlier
there there's not a coordinated effort
to like normalize these things that
Epstein and Maxwell did in this
universities and all these things no no
listen listen great when you're talking
to the average person they know nothing
about what you just said yeah that's
that's in the weeds you know inside
baseball but they have heard of Epstein
or at the very least a little bit like
oh yeah that trial that's going on being
like hey how about we get this
information thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel Monday through Friday at
8pm now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time